Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
We just got a much
more formal announcement about Jason Momoa
becoming the new Lobo for Superman Legacy
in James Gunn's rebooted DCU movies,
and they clarified
what's going on with all the other Justice
League characters from the Snyderverse.
There were a couple of questions
we knew about a couple of people
being recast, but now we know everything,
we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
We're getting way more announcements
and details about what
the upcoming DC movies are actually going
to look like in some teasers.
So of course I'll do videos
for all that stuff.
As we get more information.
this was Jason Momoa talking about the big
DC reboot in addition to Alchemy and two
and he still trying to hype up
Aquaman two at the time that he's saying
all this stuff, but he's also basically
saying that he's also going to be the Lobo
character What was your meeting with James
Gunn and Peter Safran like?
It's very, very wonderful.
I'm in the house of Warner Brothers
and they like him
a lot of stuff I'm doing,
and we got a lot of good things going.
11 more months until we get another movie
we're going to have.
Yeah, we'll have Aquaman, which is funny.
It's the beautiful thing is I,
me and my partner wrote
the first treatment for
it is about a 55 page treatment
and a lot of it has to deal with,
you know, you talking to the U.N.,
expediting what's going to be happening
with the melting ice caps.
And it's there's no far off galaxy
coming in to destroy us.
There's no aliens from another place.
It's really
just the idea of us ruining our planet
and the fact that we all need
to get it together and save save our home.
So it's it's it's it's fun to see me
coming out and this this December.
And then,
you know, I'll always be Aquaman.
The rumors are I'll always be Aquaman
and want to go and take
And then there might be
some other characters too. So.
Oh, so we can play.
I can play other things too.
I can be funny and savage and charming
once in a while.
at the time they released this clip of him
talking about Lobo earlier this year.
I think Jason Momoa honestly believed
there was still a chance
that he could play both the Aquaman
character in the new DCU movies
and the Lobo character.
so a lot of people were just like,
Why doesn't he just do both characters?
They could do that
because they can make him
look very different as the Lobo character
is the same thing with Josh Brolin playing
both Thanos and the Cable character
Kevin Foggy
said that he could totally come back
as cable in the upcoming Marvel movies.
but then.
James Gunn clarified things a little bit
more in this recent report about Lobo.
Seems pretty vital
the all the Justice League characters
in the Zack Snyder
version of the team will be recast.
And Jason Momoa is only going to play
the new version of Lobo.
I'm totally fine with that.
He could play a badass version of Lobo,
but the upside being
also that we might see him
as soon as Superman Legacy.
I wasn't expecting to see Lobo
in Superman Legacy,
But when we started hearing about Lobo
and we heard that the new Superman
would be
a much younger version of the character,
I was using the Superman Man of Tomorrow
movie as a good example then,
because that's the movie
very early in Superman's career
and one of the first big villains
that he fights is the Lobo character.
so literally there's the potential
that we could actually see a live action
version of something like this.
But there's already so many characters
in Superman Legacy,
James Gunn announced several,
including the brand new version
of Green Lantern,
played by Nathan Fillion.
But he said
there would be more characters,
and he only just announced a few of them.
we already know a little bit
about what's going on in that movie
and who some of the villains are.
It sounds like Brainiac is actually going
to wind up being the main villain.
There have been talks
about doing him in the Superman movies
like the Henry Cavill version of Superman
for a long time.
And had they made Man of Steel, too,
I think the brainiac would have been
the villain of that movie, too.
but. The Lobo character
probably one of the perfect characters
for Jason Momoa to play.
most long time
comic book fans would probably say
he should have always
been the Lobo character.
I think he did a fine job
as Zack Snyder's version of Aquaman,
like he can do the dark
and stormy
version of the character that he is
and the Zack Snyder
version of Justice League.
in, He can also do the Himbo
Super over-the-top big,
dumb animal version of the character
they did in the first Aquaman movie.
Like, he has a huge range
when it comes to like, really dark
and really silly, over-the-top characters.
but if you remember, the tone of
those movies is just completely different.
It's kind of weird how different they are.
you can definitely tell they tried
to pivot hard on the darker tone
about NBC's Superman, the Justice League.
Snyder cut with the first Aquaman movie.
It was way sillier.
probably one of the other best examples
of Jason Momoa being super
over-the-top would be his Fast
and Furious Dante character.
Jason Momoa can do it all.
The beauty of the Lobo character, though,
is that he's sort of the midpoint between
those different versions of Aquaman
that he's been in the DC movies.
Lobo is super dark, but at the same time
very, very over-the-top
like a more toned down
version of Jason Momoa's Dante character
in Fast and the Furious.
this is a testament to how crazy he is
in that Fast and Furious movie.
Let me know in the comments
what you want to see from Jason
MOMOA'S Lobo and which other characters
besides the new Superman
Do you want to see him crossover with now,
the same report explained
that he's going to be the new Lobo
in Superman Legacy.
Also says
they're probably going
to do a Lobo solo movie
or they're trying
to develop one of some kind.
So we'll be totally fine.
They just use a small scene,
a Superman legacy to set up the character.
Then they did a deep dive
into his backstory in his corner
of the DC Universe in his solo movie.
like Superman Legacy
isn't going to be like a five hour movies.
They don't have time to do
everybody is deep dive.
it if they do
wind up doing a Lobo solo movie,
it would be really cool if they did it.
Rated R and since James Gunn did
one of the few rated RDC movies,
you know that it's totally possible.
I don't think that he's afraid
of doing more rated R movies.
way back before.
Jason
Momoa was originally cast as all command.
There were rumors at the time
that he was almost cast as Lobo.
This would have been ten years
or more ago,
but the regime at Warner Brothers
at the time didn't
want to do rated RDC movies.
They didn't care about the Lobo character.
They only wanted to focus on the main
Justice League characters
because they were racing towards Justice
League in the Lobo idea
was basically thrown away at the time.
but this is just an example
of how at the time the people
who were developing these movies at DC
way back in the day
thought
that he would make an awesome Lobo.
So people had that idea a long time ago.
in it sounds like Jason Momoa
was really on board with that idea too.
Like, he sounds like you would've
been totally happy
becoming a Lobo instead of Aquaman.
This was him coming out of a meeting
with the Warner
Brothers Powers that be after
the big reboot had been announced.
In the four years.
Four years ago,
I had the tip of five foot four.
Don't know. No,
I was, you know, four years ago.
I was screaming, wasn't screaming
when I left Warner Brothers,
everyone's in the mini
four years.
Again, it's a mystery, baby.
We got I got some really good news.
Great news with Warner Brothers.
Amazing.
Wish I could tell you, but here it is.
Peter, I love you, James.
I love you,
David.
Okay.
Back to the future.
To the future.
They're all pushing me rolling.
see how happy he is about the idea
that he's
going to become the new version of Lobo.
It sounds like they basically
told him what we saw in this report.
Like, okay, we're going to shutter
this Aquaman portrayal.
Like,
you were a great version
of this character,
but we're going to move on
to something different
and we're going to have you come back
and do your thing
with a completely different character
that's a little more appropriate
to your talents.
the bigger thing now, though,
like the big elephant in the room,
is the fact
they're still charging ahead with alchemy.
And two, later this year and James Gunn
just came out and said,
no DC movies of any kind are truly canon
to his new rebooted DCU until Creature
Commandos in Superman Legacy.
There are couple exceptions
when it comes to characters
like we know Blue Beetle's coming back.
James Gunn was very clear about that.
He confirmed that the Peacemaker
characters are coming back,
including Amanda Waller.
He's going to make Peacemaker Season
two after Superman Legacy.
There were a ton of follow up
questions, too.
People ask him how you handle the reboot
continuity with the new timeline
in Peacemaker Season two,
because all the Season one stuff
took place in the Snyder verse.
he literally met those Justice
League characters in the finale,
paying off all his alchemy and jokes
that he'd been telling the entire season,
according to James Gunn,
they'll deal with the continuity issue
in the beginning of season two.
And I really hope
I really hope he's going to go
with something close to my fan theory.
A lot of you
probably have this theory, too.
peacemakers, whole thing.
Is he just a crazy conspiracy theorist
who spouts off all the time
about his crazy theories?
You make him be kind of like the psycho
pirate of the rebooted DCU movies
during the original crisis
on Infinite Earths comics
when DC rebooted his entire comic book
line, Psycho Pirate was like
the one guy doomed to remember everything
that happened before the reboot.
He remembered all the worlds
in the characters that had died
in the new DCU movies.
You can just make Peacemaker
that only character
who remembers the original Snyder verse,
and he starts spouting off
about the universe,
changing all the Justice
League actors being different.
What happened to Superman?
Why does he look different now?
Why does Batman look different now?
What happened?
in none of the other Peacemaker
characters believe him
because they think he's a total nut
and will believe anything he sees.
Like the Superman jokes during season one.
James going to explain
this when season one was coming out,
he said that peacemakers whole thing is
that he believes anything he reads online,
no matter how ridiculous it sounds
or who wrote it.
but. Aquaman two Lost
Kingdom is the next big DC movie.
It's still a Snyder verse movie with Jason
Momoa Aquaman.
the way the James Wan and James
Gunn said that they're handling that.
It's just making the movie
very self-contained.
Not a ton of big Justice League
crossovers.
mostly the same way
the Blue Beetle movie treated
the rest of the Justice League universe.
there were a lot of Superman,
Batman, Justice League references.
There were even Green Lantern references
that the directors confirmed in the movie.
But because they didn't show you
those characters faces on screen,
the movie could have been referencing
any versions of those characters
as opposed to the Flash movie,
which is like the opposite.
It leaned hard into the Snyder verse
Justice League
characters with Ben Affleck,
Batman, Gal Gadot, Wonder Woman.
There were a ton of Henry
Cavill Superman deleted scenes
because they were setting up DC movies
that were planned before James
Gunn came along to do his big reboot.
but according to this report,
and as far as I know,
none of the Aquaman characters
from either of the two movies will
come back as their characters in the vast
majority of them won't come back at all.
ladies.
The memo is one of the few exceptions,
and then he's coming back,
even though it's as a Lobo, not as Aquaman
the other funny thing
a lot of you probably saw in
your feeds recently is that DC
Comics just started dressing Lobo up
as Aquaman for Halloween
and making a bunch of Jason Momoa jokes.
those DC comic book writers
know exactly what they're doing.
Like haha, yes.
Jason Momoa will soon be
both Aquaman and Lobo or
he will have been Aquaman,
but will be a Lobo as well.
I've already done
a bunch of Superman legacy videos
for all the stuff that we know so far.
The Batman Penguin HBO series and Creature
Commandos
are like the next big TV series
that they're going to be doing.
I'll do episode videos for those,
but it'll probably be a little while
before we actually get trailers for those.
Click here to learn about the new version
of Nathan Fillion Green Lantern
and that new version
of the Justice League in the DCU
and click here
to learn about all the Henry
Cavill Superman
deleted scenes from the Flash movie.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!